in many ways life is like one big party
it is a gathering of energy and a
celebration of existence the point of a
party is to experience connection
opportunity and excitement and the point
of life itself is to fulfill these same
qualities like a party life should
stimulate an appreciation of existence
and collectivity it should make us
nervous and excited at the same time it
should open us up to new people and new
experiences
needless to say everything we do in life
may not be as fun as a party but if we
approach everything with the mindset
that life is a continuous effort to
celebrate and connect with life itself
our perspectives and experiences will
begin to change things that would
otherwise seem simple or dull will start
to elicit significance and wonder one of
our strongest desires is to feel
perpetually intoxicated by the substance
of wonder to look out the window of our
bedroom and see the same trees the same
street and the same grass that we have
seen a million times yet still feel
amazed and inspired as if it was the
first time seeing it we want to
constantly feel the sensation of what
our infant self felt when stepping into
consciousness for the first time
experiencing the thrilling mystery of
the relationship between human and
nature
this desire is the reason why people do
drugs drink alcohol and party in the
first place to escape normal life and
feel excitement and stimulation but if
we view life as a party in itself we
will constantly feeling toxicated by
life's wonder and no longer feel the
need to escape it we will no longer have
to worry about the feeling of waking up
in the morning after a party upset that
it has ended thank you for watching if
you found enjoyment and value in this
video please give it a thumbs up share
your thoughts in the comments below and
if you are not already be sure to
subscribe to our Channel
we are constantly coming out with new
videos to help you experience life with
clarity and Wonder